will there be a war between us and china
in the 21st century
if there is
we're finished
okay
a war between
the us and china
would destroy the possibilities of
organized life on earth
in fact we can put it differently
unless the u.s and china
reach an accommodation
and work together and cooperatively
it's very unlikely that
organized human society will survive
we are facing enormous problems
problems
destruction of the environment
endemics
threat of nuclear war
none of these
decline of
a democratic functioning of an arena for
rational discourse
that none of these things have
boundaries
we either work together to overcome it
overcome them which we can do
or will all sync together
that's the real question we should be
asking
what the united states is doing
is not helping
uh
so current u.s policy which is
perfectly open nothing secret about it
is to
what's called encircle china
it's the official word
with
sentinel states
uh south korea
japan uh
australia
which will be heavily armed
uh provided by biden with precision
weapons
aimed at china
backed by a
major
naval operations huge naval operation
just took place
in the pacific
many nations participating rim bank
didn't get reported here as far as i
know but an enormous operation
threatening china
all of this to
encircle china
to
continue with policies like that
somebody like pelosi
uh just to
probably to
make her look more
i don't know what
what her motives are
taking a highly provocative
stupid act opposed
by the military opposed by the white
house well yes acts like that which of
course
called forth the response
of highly dangerous
uh we don't have to do that we don't
have to increase
the threat i mean right now the last
nato summit
take a look at it
for the first time
it invited
uh to attend
the countries
that are in the the sentinel states
surrounding china and circling china
from the east
and it in fact extended
the range of nato
to what's called the indo-pacific region
so all of us by now the north atlantic
includes the whole indo-pacific region
to try to
ensure that we can
overcome the so-called china threat
fortunately we might ask exactly what
the china threat is
it's done sometimes
so
former prime minister of
australia paul keating
well-known international diplomat
i had an article a while ago in the
australian press
that's right in the claws of the dragon
asking
going through what the china threat is
he ran through the various claims
finally concluded
the china threat is that china exists
it exists it does not follow u.s orders
it's not like europe
europe does what the united states tells
it to do
even if it doesn't like it
china just ignores what the us is
now there's a
formal way of describing this
there are
two versions of the international order
one version
is the un-based international order
which
theoretically we subscribe to but we
don't accept
the un-based international order is
unacceptable to the united states
because it bans u.s foreign policy
literally
it explicitly
bans the threat or use of force in
international affairs
except under circumstances that almost
never arise
well that's u.s foreign policy
try to find the president who isn't
engaged in the threat or use of force in
international affairs
okay so obviously we can't accept the
un-based
uh
international system
even though under the constitution
that's the supreme law of the land it
doesn't matter
so the united states has
what's called a rule-based international
order
that's acceptable
because it's the united states that sets
the rules
so
we want a rule-based international order
where the u.s hits the rules
in commentary in the united states
even in scholarship
it's almost 100 percent
calling for a rule-based international
order
is that false no it's true
is it propaganda of course it's
propaganda
because of what's not said and because
of what's presupposed
an answer to an earlier question
well
china does not accept the rule-based
international order
so when the u.s
imposes demands
your may not like them but they follow
them
china ignores them
so take for example the
u.s sanctions on iran
the u.s has to punish iran
because the united states pulled out of
the unilaterally pulled out of the
ukraine the iran nuclear agreements
so in order to punish
iran for error wrecking the agreements
in violation of security council orders
we impose very harsh sanctions
the europe
strongly opposes the sanctions
condemn them harshly
but it
it adheres to them
because
you don't
disobey us orders that's too dangerous
china ignores them
they're not keeping to the
rule-based international order
well
that's unacceptable
in fact it's said pretty openly
you can hear
the secretary of state and others saying
uh china is challenging our global
hegemony yes they are
they don't accept u.s global hegemony
especially in the waters off china
so
that's the china threat they do a lot of
rotten things china
i mean internally there's all kind of
repression violence and so on
but first of all it's not a threat to us
and second the us doesn't care about it
because it easily accepts and supports
comparable crimes and atrocities
internal to allies
so yes we should protest it but without
hypocrisy
we have no standing to protest it we
supported comparable things and all
sorts of other places
and just take a look at the
us foreign aid
the leading recipient is uf foreign aid
is israel
which is engaged in constant
terror violence and repression
constant almost daily
second leading recipient is
egypt under the worst dictatorship in
egypt's history
about 60 000
people in jail prison political
prisoners tortured and so on do we care
no second leading recipient
i mean
what are we talking about that's why the
most of the world just laughs at us
you go to there's a lot of
uh
failure to understand here about why the
global south doesn't join us
in our
uh
proxy war against russia
fighting russia until it's severely
weakened
they don't join us
here the question is what's wrong with
them
look into their minds to figure out
what's wrong
and they have a different attitude
they say yes we
oppose
the invasion of ukraine
terrible crime but what are you talking
about
this is what you do to us all the time
you don't care about crimes like this
that's most of the global self
we can't comprehend that
because we're so insulated
that we are just obviously right and
everyone who doesn't go along must be
wrong
you